♪ ♪
>> Jesse: AFTER RANTING ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S BEHAVIOR,
ACTOR ROBERT DE NIRO ISN'T BIG
LEGAL TROUBLE OVER HIS OWN
CONDUCT.
A FORMER ASSISTANT SLAPPING THE
ACTOR WITH THE $12 MILLION
LAWSUIT FOR ABUSIVE AND SEXIST
COMMENTS.
THIS EXPLETIVE-FILLED VOICE MAIL
IS AT THE CENTER OF THE DISPUTE.
>> YOU [BLEEP].
DON'T ANSWER MY CALL.
HOW DARE YOU?
YOU ARE [BLEEP] HISTORY.
HOW DARE YOU DISRESPECT ME?
[BLEEP].
DON'T GET ANGRY WITH ME.
I DIDN'T GET A SINGLE THING I
NEED.
I'M HERE FOR LESS THAN 24 HOURS,
YOU'VE GOT TO BE [BLEEP] KIDDING
ME.
YOU SPOILED BRAT.
[BLEEP] YOU.
HOW CAN YOU -- YOU ARE UPSET.
YOU ARE LIVING IN SPACE.
YOU SPOILED [BLEEP] BRAT.
>> Jesse: WAS THAT
""GOODFELLAS"?"
YOU CAN'T TELL THE DIFFERENCE.
>> Juan: ITS OFFENSIVE
BEHAVIOR.
IT REMINDED ME OF THE CALL
BETWEEN ALEC BALDWIN AND HIS
DAUGHTER WHICH WAS EVEN WORSE.
I SAY, I SUSPECT YOU ARE DOING
THIS BECAUSE HE IS ANTI-TRUMP.
>> Greg: HOW DARE YOU, JUAN?
I AM OUTRAGED.
>> Juan: YOU SHOULD BE
OUTRAGED, IMAGINE SOMEBODY SUING
BECAUSE THEY HAVE A RUDE,
OFFENSIVE BOSS?
OH, MY GOSH!
>> Jesse: OTHER THINGS IN THE
LAWSUIT WERE MORE SERIOUS.
HE SUED HER I GUESS BEFORE SHE
COULD SUE HIM.
>> Greg: HERE'S THE OUTRAGEOUS
THING.
SHE BINGE WATCHED 50 EPISODES OF
"FRIENDS" WHILE AT WORK.
I'M SORRY, BUT YOU DESERVE TO BE
SUED FOR THAT.
I DO THINK, SHE WORKED WITH HIM.
TEN YEARS.
IT SEEMS LIKE A CASHING IN KIND
OF THING.
I WOULD LIKE TO -- IS MUCH AS I
WOULD LIKE TO CRAP ALL OVER
DE NIRO.
HE'S A HYPOCRITE, USES TERRIBLE
LANGUAGE.
HE NEVER HAS A REASON, HE DOES
THE AWLS ABOUT IT.
>> Dana: IT'S SHOCKING TO HEAR
IT AND I GO BACK, I'VE BEEN
WORKING FOR A LONG TIME, I'VE
NEVER BEEN IN THE SITUATION
WHERE YOU HAD A BOSS THAT WAS
SAYING THINGS LIKE THAT.
IT'S NEVER HAPPENED TO ME.
>> Greg: I HAVE HEARD YOUR
ASSISTANT TALK ABOUT YOU.
[LAUGHTER]
OH, MY GOD.
HOLY TOLEDO.
>> Greg: NO YELLING.
>> Jesse: NOT EVEN DURING THE
IRAQ WAR?
>> Dana: NO YELLING.
>> Katie: I'M WITH GREG.
TEN YEARS LATER, THESE LAWSUITS
ALWAYS BRING OUT A LITTLE MORE
INFORMATION THAT'S IN THE NEWS
REPORTING BEING PUSHED BY THE
LAWYERS FOR BOTH SIDES.
I WILL TAKE A STEP BACK AND BE
THE BIGGER PERSON AND ALTHOUGH
ROBERT DE NIRO HAS THOUGHTS
ABOUT US AT FOX NEWS, I'M NOT
GOING TO REPAY THE FAVOR AND
I'LL SAY GOOD LUCK TO BOTH
SIDES.
NOT GOING TO TAKE ASIDE AND YOU
CAN FIGHT IT OUT IN COURT.
>> Juan: I THINK THAT HUG
MUST'VE HAD AN IMPACT.
>> Katie: WE ARE ALL CHANGED.